what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future so Tana ha sees black
panther 4 all-new all-different marvel
it's one of the best stories coming out
a marvel right now and there's no two
ways about it I mean this story is
amazing and here's a reason why
historically speaking Black Panther has
had a very long history you know very
lengthy and rich history only insofar as
him being part of a superhero team he
was a major character in the Marvel
community because he was like the first
major black superhero in Marvel Comics
and because of that it set the stage for
a storm and you know Sam Wilson and Luke
Cage and all those different guys but
there were only like glimpses that we
ever got of Wakanda unless it was like a
backup feature or unless it was
something where the Fantastic Four or
the Avengers or Captain America travel
to a Condon we almost never learned
about his home territory the only time
we ever really saw anything going on
with the Khanda and even then the
villains that we saw the only real
expansion that we had was if like mbaku
man ape was like trying to take over
Wakanda usurped the throne of King from
T'Challa and cast him out or someone
like Erik kill monger was trying to get
rid of black panther that was really
about it now a lot of that changed in
the 1990s with white Panther vol 3 when
we had Christopher priest take over the
title the issue here was that
Christopher priests focused more on like
the political story telling of what
Conda more so than expanding the history
of Wakanda itself he did to a degree but
it was always like what black panther
was doing in the United States but what
black panther was doing in Wakanda in a
small section of it
what Tallahassee does here is he shows
us that there's trouble in paradise that
yes black panther is a king but there's
a lot more to being a king than just
being a guy who runs the show and that's
the coolest thing here now something to
keep in mind is a ton of houses writing
comes out of the events before Secret
Wars so you know we're talking about
stories where Doctor Doom invaded
Wakanda we're talking about the Cabal
the Black Order of Thanos when they
invaded Wakanda we're talking about
Avengers vs. x-men when they when the
Submariner flooded Wakanda there were a
lot of events that took place here that
really impacted Wakanda in such a way
that it left a bad taste in everybody's
mouth and people be
and a question to Charlie himself now no
event was more significant than the
death of Sheree because at the time when
she died she had effectively replaced a
black panther as ruler of Wakanda and
during the events leading up to secret
Wars as part of Hickman's Avengers and
new Avengers where he was able to
bolster things introduce stuff like
necrosha the city of the Dead black
panther communicating with the ghosts of
past Black Panthers that were part of
the ruling monarchy in Wakanda itself
Shuri had basically sacrificed her life
she had paved the way for as many people
to escape as they could or at least from
like Panther and its sources to escape
while she stayed behind and effectively
died because of that people in a lot of
ways that people would in Wakanda itself
looked to him as a coward they looked to
him as a person who wasn't effectively a
king now what that means will be
explored later on and in fact there's a
beautifully crafted conversation between
a woman named Ramon de and de Charla
himself where she basically says how
you've been acting as a king is not what
gets people to believe that you're a
king it makes them think you're a king
but they don't believe it in their heart
of hearts they just say yes he's King
now the cool thing about this is we
initially start off with Tana hosta
basically showing us that there is
trouble here that T'Challa in Wakanda
right now is effectively dealing with
the early stages of insurrection that
there is really right now at this moment
an organization called the people that's
effectively launching a series of
terrorist attacks now the way they
launch these attacks are simply done by
a woman who's effectively bringing out
the emotions that people already have
and then using that for them to carry
out a multitude of different acts so
we're this group called that people will
carry out acts in and of themselves it's
easier to basically get what Condon's to
commit these acts on their own now it's
really just them rebelling it's them you
know refusing to work or it's them you
know effectively lashing out at Black
Panther by way of just tearing things up
but the fact remains here that is
effectively creating this kind of rift
in Wakanda itself to where the people of
Wakanda don't quite have the same faith
in Black Panther that they used to now
at this point we switch over to the
capital of Wakanda to the Golden City as
its referred to now this is actually
extremely important because in this
particular instance they're basically a
young woman named Anika who's
essentially being put on trial here and
the reason why is because there was a
chieftain in a part of Wakanda who is
essentially going around
abusing women in different ways and
because of this and he could basically
spoken up she said hey you can't do this
when the chieftain ignored her she
killed him for now the reason why she
did that is because this chieftain was
dishonouring the mothers the sisters the
daughters of various people from around
Wakanda and because of that the only way
to deal with such dishonor that was
unrepentant was to kill the person who
was doing that now the woman who's
making this case who's pleading this
argument is a girl named IO and she's
actually part of a group called the Dora
Milosh a I think is how you pronounce it
but this is basically the personal guard
of T'Challa it's really kind of you know
referred to as like his adored ones
basically the ones above all others so
whenever you see like an image or a
panel from Black Panther vol 3 where you
have two Charla like you're in the first
story arc of like have their value III
called a client where de chollet travels
to North America the people who are with
him that's part of that group now the
girl IO who's making this case is
basically say hey look she was standing
up for the honor of others the issue
here is that Ramon de is effectively
overseeing all this now again Ramon de
will get some measure of explanation
here in a second but where I o says you
have to let her go because she's
standing up for the honor of someone you
know you cannot simply condemn her for
that Ramon de says yes we do because
that is the law of the land the law of
the land must be maintained if we make
an exception for her we have to make an
exception for somebody else and then the
problem becomes the line-drawing
now following this where Anika is she's
not really executed so much as she's
held prisoner until she's executed we
basically pick up with the arrival of
T'Challa here where he starts talking
with Ramon de and what we learn here is
that Ramon does the second wife of his
father to Chaka but she is as much his
mother as his biological mother now keep
in mind the biological mother of
T'Challa had basically died in
childbirth but Ramon does not a new
creation she's been around since like
Marvel premiere a number of something
number for number 22 so I'm like that I
can't remember but she's been around for
a long time since the 1960s I think cuz
the late 1960s but she's been a major
part of the black panther mythos for
quite some time the issue is that what
tenacity is gonna do here he's basically
gonna really flesh her out more that
she's ever been fleshed out before now
what we also learned from Black Panther
is that this particular woman who was
using her powers to incite revolution is
again part of this group called the
people not only
Romana begins sitting down with like
Panther and saying hey look you have to
look at things from their perspective
from the people of Wakanda it's been
nothing but a series of problems
regicide when Sheree was killed you know
you've had cataclysms where again name
of the Submariner flooded Wakanda where
Nicosia was destroyed by family I mean
you have all these major issues that are
taking place and because of that that
people have basically lost faith in him
now in the midst of all this while this
conversation is going on we essentially
have IO basically leave the Royal Guard
of black panther basically abandon it
and then rescue Anika and this is really
when we learned the two of them have a
very close relationship more so than
that they've basically come to the
conclusion that there are a lot of
people out there who are being used for
whatever reason you know existing
chieftains these rural leaders you are
essentially abusing their power but two
challahs not doing anything to stop them
and so in their mind to Travellers
basically abandon them as they're kinked
he's walked away from it now this is not
necessarily the case but again to
charles effectively coming back to all
this after secret wars remember T'Challa
remembers everything during the events
of secret Wars when the multiverse was
basically reset by Reed Richards
T'Challa was holding on to the reality
stone and so he remembers the way
everything was prior to secret wars
during secret Wars and even now and so
in his mind he's trying to cope with
this entire situation as well as cope
for the fact that his sister's dead and
come to grips with the circumstance now
from here Tonto haci Coates gets a
little interesting in terms of his
method of storytelling and the reason
why is because we again get to see a
little bit more expansion here but we
also learned that Satara is continuing
to struggle with the fact that there are
people who are trying to effectively
revolt against him but what ton of
hockey coach also does is offer a little
bit of a retcon this is what I say his
storytelling gets a little interesting
because historically speaking in terms
of the chronology of Marvel Comics and
in continuity Eric hill monger was a
long-standing villain of black panther
and it constantly tried to eliminate him
and take his place as ruler of Wakanda
the issue with this was that originally
he was basically defeated by Monica
Rambeau
however what Tallahassee coach does here
is he says no that's not the case
instead what he says is that as part of
this organization called the people this
woman is basically using her powers to
manipulate the emotions of others is a
girl names in Z and
she was essentially the one that led to
the death of Eric hill monger by
manipulating the emotions of the people
around him and having them go insane and
attack one another and so it was
essentially Tallahassee coach saying she
was the reason why Eric Hill monger died
now that's not the biggest retcon in the
world but it also does go to show that
to a degree this is all-new
all-different marvel and so while not
everything is all new and all different
it does give existing writers a chance
to switch things up a bit to change
things around to offer some different
suggestions from here and there on
what's happening now at this point we
basically switch over to a bandit
compound in northern Wakanda and again
this is really you know IO and Anika
forming their own organization and
essentially what they do is they break
into this bandit camp where these
different women are being held captive
for the purpose of these bandits using
them for their own purposes and the
result is a Tameka and IO basically free
all of them now in this process while
they're going through all this and
they're fighting all these different
phones they also begin to come to the
idea that no one man should be in charge
of what conduct that what conduct should
basically be a country ruled by the
people and for the people now this
creates an interesting situation because
again with the exception of villains
like Eric Hill monger or Mumbai coup we
had no reason to believe that anybody
within Lokhande would try to rise up and
cast off black panther just because of
the fact that as far as previous stories
went the people revered him as a leader
this is the reason why Tana haseko
striding is so cool because what is
showing us is that there are
consequences for all the things that's
happened where we would look at comic
books we would say well I mean you know
you have some war and you got Secret
Invasion and you got you know this and
this is world bigger Hulk and all icons
look what he knows events just happen
and nothing really comes of it there's a
little bit of mistrust but at the end of
the day the superheroes always come back
and win what Tana husky Coates is saying
is no no it doesn't work that way even
if it's only with in Wakanda itself all
the cataclysms that have taken place
here all the problems that they face all
the struggles all the issues that have
gone on it does not go unnoticed and
much like a house that's being chipped
away bit by bit this is a scenario where
these different cataclysms have just
been chipping away at the trust that the
wakandan people have towards black
panther and the result is that they just
don't see him as being a capable leader
anymore
they don't see him as somebody who can
basically be their king now again we'll
get to that discussion here in a second
in terms of why threw guards to their
own personal motivations and in their
heart
but at this point we basically switch
over to Tallahassee coats building the
plotlines for a bigger story later on
and what this does is it actually picks
up with the idea of Cherie we normally
would have thought that Cherie was dead
and two degrees she was I mean it was
verified that she was dead in New
Avengers number 29 I think when we
basically saw her spirit among all the
other spirits of the wakandan leaders of
the past but not speaking up with her
character we basically joined her in the
jaw Lea I think is how you pronounce it
I'm not really familiar with a lot of
words that are of African dialect so
hopefully I pronounced it correctly but
it's basically the plane of wakandan
memory now this is a really cool concept
because within the wakandan mythos and
really the black panther mythos there
have been small expansions here and
there but nothing like this the only
thing that we ever really saw when it
came to the idea of like an afterlife it
came to the idea of other beings leaders
people who had touched with up like
Panther from the past only really came
in the form of really the Panther got
bast and what Hickman did with nicosia
and the former leaders of Wakanda
communing with Black Panther that was
about it
what we get here is this whole cool
plane of memory we get to that here in a
second but it's really this idea this
general general purpose that all the
memory of Wakanda rested within this
plane and it's gonna be somewhat of a
return of familiarity but at this point
again we basically switch back to
northern Wakanda and to the border of
the Jabari lands now the cool thing
about this is again picking up with IO
and Anika this is just another situation
where they're bolstering their ranks
because what they do is they sit down
and they essentially say we cannot fight
this fight on our own between the two of
us we cannot do this not suddenly
because of the fact that it's just the
two of us and there are so many people
out there but because of the fact that
if Black Panther finds out what we're
doing
he will capture and kill us and he could
easily take out the two of us by himself
what we need is an army what we need are
a force of people who view everything
the same way we do and we can have that
force of people rally to our cause
and we can cast off Black Panther and
replace him with a just a fair method of
ruling now again switching back over to
Cherie to the sister of Black Panther I
love this bit of writing I mean this is
beautiful beautiful beautiful writing
here because it really touches with the
history of what Condon I really like
this is being built up because what's
happening is sure he's basically
speaking with this caretaker so to speak
of the land of Wakanda and memory and
it's really this idea that this
caretaker basically said
you were a leader of Wakanda and in a
lot of ways you are a better leader than
Black Panther than your brother was and
the reason why is because you to some
degree recognize the value the intrinsic
nature the history of Wakanda but sure
II didn't fully grasp it and that's what
this caretaker says is we are going to
remind you of the beauty of Wakanda
you're going to get back in touch with
the old ways now this is a beautiful
dichotomy and the reason why I say that
is because since his introduction in the
Marvel Comics Black Panthers main
emphasis has been his intelligence and
what conda's technological advancement
that's really been like the main focal
point
what Conda has the great mound of the
Giants store vibranium that almost no
one has access to except for those that
Wakanda chooses to give a sample to like
in the instance of Captain America when
a shield was created but with the
exception of that no one really has
access to it more so than that it was
always a technological advancement of
Wakanda but it wasn't a whole lot of
emphasis on the nature of Wakanda what's
beyond the technological advancement
once you get down into the roots once
you get into the land itself what is the
basis behind it that's what Tata hasi is
basically exploring here is this idea of
the history of Wakanda what Conda had
this rich powerful history long before
vibranium showed up and it'll have the
rich powerful history presumably
somewhere along the line somebody takes
all that vibranium and so a gift from
here we really switch over to Black
Panther he's he's continuing his hunt
for Zinzi and ultimately he comes across
her the problem is that he also comes
across a guy named tatu I think it is
her t2 and he's basically this guy who's
working alongside Zindzi now again this
is a guy that basically invokes magic
it's really just kind of like control of
the land is really what he does his
powers seem to be more akin to like
black Tom Cassidy those who guys
remember that far back but the idea here
is that he basically tells why Panther
you're a failure of a king with all the
calamities that we've had all the
destruction that we faced were were you
were worried you when the crow sure came
crashing down where were you when dr.
doom invaded Wakanda where were you in
name of the sub-mariner flooded Wakanda
where were you during all these major
calamities you were off with the
Avengers you were off gallivanting
around with people who are not wakandan
born and essentially what he's saying is
you've abandoned your heritage now there
is some very powerful messages coming
out of this because
what tattoos really doing is cooing the
sentiment of existing wakandans that
yeah sure if black panther is their king
yeah sure black panther is part of the
monarchy he's a royal blood but he's not
acting like a king he's acting like a
guy who's just there for a while who's
just occupying your space and just going
through the motions and doing whatever
it is that a king does it's almost like
one of these circumstances where he
would rather be on the Avengers team he
would rather be off in space fighting
some foe or trying to deal with Thanos
when he's got some you know insane
scheme going on but he doesn't really
want to be a king now the reason why
this is important is because following
the escape of Tatooine ends in Z we
basically have black panther sitting
down and talking with Raimondo basically
talking with his mother now she says
this is exactly right like what t2 is
saying is essentially right he's making
a legitimate claim here that the
difference between being a king and
people believing you're a king is
inspiration it's not enough to just be
the guy in charge it's not enough to be
the guy that people look up to you you
have to inspire them you have to give
them a reason to believe in you and that
is the most important thing here and the
reason for that I guess a really perfect
example of that is like world war ii
japan the japanese people will lay down
their lives for Hirohito that's why we
dropped atomic bombs instead of invading
because they would have fought to the
last man woman and child
that's essentially what ramond is
talking about here with black panther of
course she doesn't invoke World War 2 or
anything like that but she's saying the
people have to believe in you they have
to to truly believe in their heart of
hearts that you're looking out for them
that you're doing the best that you can
because if you don't then all they're
going to do is see a series of
calamities and they're going to see that
you don't care and so she says if you
want to prevent more of these major
crises if you want to keep more of these
things from happening then you have to
convince the people to believe in you
and so that when someone comes along
like Zinzi and she uses her power to
bring out their utmost emotions that in
the end they turn against her because
their strongest emotion is love for
T'Challa love for Black Panther the
issue with this is that while he's going
through and while he's spending time
with these people while he has this
major ceremony and he's talking to all
of his subordinates there's a massive
explosion in the background and when
this massive explosion is done you know
when it all begins to clear up there's
massive casualties across the board even
Raimondo herself the mother
like Panther is severely injured and so
because of this he sits down with his
council and basically says this is an
act of war and I want to know who's
behind it because once we find out who's
behind it we're going to go through and
we're gonna kill them all and so what
Tana Haas he's basically doing here at
least what it seems like he's doing here
is saying hey here's a really cool story
that just shows you kind of a follow up
from the events from before secret Wars
with a guard so all the invasions and
all the calamities and so on and so
forth here's how all that panned out
with regards to a Conda and here is why
Panther basically going through thinning
the herd trimming the fat getting rid of
all these insurrectionist groups and
then presumably going forward having a
better understanding of what it means to
actually be a king but if you guys are
new here to comics explain make sure you
guys have the subscribe button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah as far as I'm concerned this is the
best Black Panthers story ever told like
it is it's amazing it's only book one I
think you're surviving like three or
four books but they're basically volumes
is essentially what they are but it's
extremely well-written I highly suggest
you check it out if you ever get a
chance but yeah guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]